أجنبية
بمبانيها الفريدة ، وهي مزيج من
التصميم العربي والتقنيات الحديثة ،
تزعم مدينة مازدا في ضواحي أبو ظبي في الإمارات العربية المتحدة أنها من بين أكثر المدن
استدامة في العالم ، فهي في
طليعة ثورة الكربون في العالم التي
نرى العالم يصنع منها
بيان يقول بأننا سنكون محايدًا للكربون
بحلول عام 2050. لدينا الكثير
من العمل الذي يتعين علينا القيام به ، ولدينا الكثير من العمل الذي يتعين
القيام به في كل منطقة للوصول إلى هذا الهدف وهو
أحد أكثر الأهداف طموحًا في
العالم  في أي وقت مضى ، فإن
محيطاتنا هي التي يمكن أن تحمل مفتاح
تحقيق هذا الهدف المحايد للكربون وقد
قام هؤلاء العلماء في جامعة كاليفورنيا لوس أنجلوس
بالتحقيق في إمكاناته ،
لذا فإن المحيط يخزن ما يقرب من 150
مرة من ثاني أكسيد الكربون أكثر من
الغلاف الجوي ، لذا فإن عمليتنا تزيل  ثاني أكسيد الكربون
من الغلاف الجوي من خلال
الاستفادة من قوة المحيط
لامتصاص ثاني أكسيد الكربون بشكل طبيعي من الهواء
في تجارب علمية قاموا بسحب
مياه البحر من خلال شبكة من الأكواب
وأنابيب الاختبار ، وكان الهدف هو فصل ثاني أكسيد الكربون
عن مياه البحر ، وهذا هو منتجنا
هنا.  هو محلول سائل صلب ،
هذا هو ثاني أكسيد الكربون الذي تم التقاطه ،
يطلق عليه تقنية احتجاز الكربون ،
تتعرض مياه البحر من المحيط
لشحنة كهربائية من خلال
تفاعلات كيميائية ، يتم فصل ثاني أكسيد الكربون والماء عن ثاني
أكسيد الكربون المحاصر الآن في شكل صلب يتم
ضخه مرة أخرى في المحيط  وتخزينها في
قاع البحر ، يتم إرسال الماء الذي لم يعد
يحتوي على ثاني أكسيد الكربون إلى المحيط أيضًا
حيث يكون جاهزًا مرة أخرى لامتصاص
المزيد من ثاني أكسيد الكربون من الغلاف الجوي ،
وتمثل هذه الخلية المسطحة الصغيرة هذه
بالتأكيد صناعتها الخاصة التي تمضي
قدمًا في إزالة ثاني أكسيد الكربون  ستكون
الصناعة الثقيلة الجديدة التي يتعين على البشرية
تطويرها من أجل معالجة
عواقب الثورة الصناعية الأولى
التي أدت إلى إطلاق
كميات كبيرة من ثاني أكسيد الكربون على مدى
فترات زمنية قصيرة
في ميناء لوس أنجيليس ما
بدأ
العنصر  لقد تطورت إلى دليل على
مشروع مفهوم على هذه البارجة التي يبلغ ارتفاعها 100 قدم والتي
تصورنا أن الخطوة التالية ستكون
عملية يبلغ حجمها حوالي مائة مرة
حجم هذا لتكون قائمة بذاتها على Shore
ومن ثم ستكون الخطوة التالية هي
عملية مئات المرات  أكبر
من ذلك ،
يقول دانتي إنهم يخططون لنشر هذه
التكنولوجيا تجاريًا في غضون خمس
سنوات ، وإذا نجحت ، فقد تقطع
شوطًا طويلاً لتحقيق الهدف العالمي المتمثل في
أن تكون محايدًا للكربون بحلول عام 2050.